THE CENTER OF A CONTROVERSY OVER
PAY INCREASES AT THE EPA.
>> Shannon: JOHN ROBERTS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THANK YOU.
NORMALLY IT'S THE FBI ON THE
SIDE OF PROSECUTORS OFFERING
DEALS TO POTENTIAL CRIMINAL
WITNESSES.
TONIGHT, THE FORMER NUMBER TWO
MAN AT THE FBI IS SEEKING
IMMUNITY FOR HIMSELF.
ANDREW MCCABE WANTS A PROTECTION
IN EXCHANGE FOR TELLING CONGRESS
BUT HE KNOWS ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAILS.
ALSO, A NEW REPORT TAKING ISSUE
WITH THE FORMER HEAD MAN AT THE
BUREAU AND HOW HE DID HIS JOB.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS DETAILS
ON THE DEVELOPMENT.
>> THESE BETTER GENERALS REPORT
PUTS DIRECTOR COMEY'S LEADERSHIP
STYLE UNDER THE MICROSCOPE WITH
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL EXPLORING
WHETHER COMEY WENT BEYOND HIS
AUTHORITY'S IN JULY 2016 WHEN HE
PUBLICLY DISCUSSED THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION AND
RECOMMENDED AGAINST CRIMINAL
CHARGES AND RESPONSIBILITY THAT
FELT AS COST THE TIME,
ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA LYNCH.
COMEY EXPLAINED THAT LYNCH'S
ARIZONA TARMAC MEETING WITH THE
CLINTON DAYS BEFORE HEATHER
CLINTON'S FBI INTERVIEW FROM
MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WAS A GAME-CHANGER.
IN ADDITION TO OTHER
INTELLIGENCE, AND APPLIED LYNCH
WOULD NOT LET THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION GO TOO FAR.
THAT INTELLIGENCE IS NOT PUBLIC
AND ITS LIABILITY AND CLEAR.
ON, FORMER DIRECTOR CHOSE HIS
WORDS CAREFULLY ABOUT LYNCH.
>> I THINK WE ARE BOTH TELLING
THE TRUTH.
I NEVER WENT TO HER AND SEND
LORETTA COME I THINK YOU SHOULD
RECUSE YOURSELF.
THE PROBLEM WAS SHE ALREADY
ANNOUNCED PUBLICLY THAT SHE
WOULDN'T AND THEN SHE WOULD
ACCEPT MY RECOMMENDATION.
AT THAT POINT, WHAT DO I DO?
I DECIDED I HAVE TO STEP AWAY.
>> FOX NEWS CONFIRMS FORMER FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE
WHO WORKED DIRECTLY UNDER COMEY
WANTS A SPECIAL STATUS IF HE
TESTIFIES ON CAPITOL HILL.
IT'S CALLED USE IMMUNITY AND IT
MEANS THE CASE TESTIMONY CANNOT
BE USED AGAINST HIM IN A
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND THAT
McCABE LIED UNDER OATH AND
MADE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO THE
U.S. ATTORNEY HERE IN D.C. FOR
LYING TO FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS.
SENIOR SENATOR REPUBLICAN ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
AGAINST A DEAL TO SECURE
McCABE'S TESTIMONY.
>> WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT HAPPENED AT THE FBI
DURING THE COMEY YEARS WHERE
APPARENTLY THERE WAS MISCONDUCT
GOING ON WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
IMPUGNED THE REPUTATION OF THE
FINEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
THE WORLD.
AND WE NEED TO CLEAR THE AIR.
IMMUNITY WOULD BE A MISTAKE.
>> MCCABE'S LAWYER SAID
"McCABE IS WILLING TO TESTIFY
BUT BECAUSE OF THE CRIMINAL
REFERRAL HE MUST BE AFFORDED
SUITABLE LEGAL PROTECTION,
ADDING IF YOU WERE UNABLE TO GET
SUCH DEAL, MUGABE COULD HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO INVOKE HIS FIFTH
AMENDMENT PRIVILEGE AGAINST
SELF-DETERMINATION."
TESTIMONY IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY BEFORE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WOULD THAT
HAS THE LEAD ON THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT THAT